[Music]
so here are shots of all we trade in the
currency of optimism we're tired of doom
and gloom fatalistic thinking the world
is going to hell and all that we need
solutions to address the grand
challenges of humanity see I believe in
boundless possibility human beings are a
curious species because we have the
ability to conceive it delightful exotic
future scenarios and we can actually
move the popular will we can pull the
present forward and meet and actualize
any of those possibilities that's what
we do we pull the present forward into
the future the future that we create we
map out today
you hear a lot in the media about the
energy crisis we hear a lot about
sustainability your a lot about
strolling the planet these are all
legitimate concerns but again doom and
gloom has been fatigued we need
solutions so let's talk about the
solutions project the solutions project
is an amazing new initiative led by
Hollywood celebrities brilliant civil
engineers the popular will of some of
the smartest and in the world will come
together to leverage their brains to
create a plan to take us 100% renewable
here in America literally 50 plans for
50 states by 2050
today the proposal is straightforward
eliminate combustion as a source of
energy the Sun gives us a one single
hour more energy that we would need to
power the earth for a year and the
technology used to capture that energy
is getting exponentially faster all the
time the fact that less than 2% of the
United States landmass would support all
of the wind solar and hydroelectric
power generation required some the
energy demand is amazing now again it
all comes down to the fact that we need
to make a cognitive leap we need to
realize this is already possible now
today with existing technology you
change Minds you change paradigms so
again I encourage all of you guys to
check out the Solutions project.org get
educated get involved join the
conversation thank you very much
you